CANCEL CULTURE.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU'VE BEEN VERY
CRITICAL AND SIGNED THE LETTER
THAT WAS IN HARPER'S MASH
MAGAZINE SOMETIMES CALLED
WOKENESS OR CRITICAL RACE THEORY
AND RECENTLY YOU SIGNED THING
ABOUT LEGISLATURES TRYING TO BAN
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY YOU CHANGED ON
THAT.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S NOT A
CHANGE AT ALL.
I THINK IT'S JUST STICKING WITH
A FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPAL THE
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION, THE
FREEDOM TO THINK FREELY, TO
EXPLORE IDEAS AND TO DISCUSS
IDEAS THAT ARE CONTROVERSIAL AND
THAT ARE POTENTIALLY EVEN WRONG.
AND THE WAY TO DEFEAT WRONG
IDEAS IS THROUGH PERSUASION AND
SUPERIOR IDEAS AND CLEARER
THINKING.
BUT IT'S NOT THROUGH ANY KIND OF
AUTHORITARIANISM OR BANS OR
UNDEMOCRATIC MEANS OF FORCING
PEOPLE TO THINK THE SAME, SO,
YOU KNOW, THE HARPERS LETTER WAS
A DEFENSIVE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
AND IT WAS ARGUING, YOU KNOW,
BANNING IDEAS WE THINK ARE
UNPERSUASIVE IS A REALLY BAD WAY
OF GOING ABOUT DEFENDING
SO-CALLED AND AT SOME POINT THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY WAIT, WAIT,
THAT'S GOING TOO FAR?
>> I ABSOLUTELY THINK THEY HAVE
A RIGHT TO SAY THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE PERSUASION COMES IN
AND DISCUSSION.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THESE
TYPE OF BANS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
PINPOINT WHAT IS THIS THING
BEING BANNED AND WHAT IS OUTSIDE
OF THAT.
SO YOU HAVE THESE HUGE KIND OF
MISTAKES BEING MADE WHERE A
LETTER FROM A BIRMINGHAM JAIL BY
MARTIN LUTHER KING IS BEING
BANNED BECAUSE ITS POTENTIAL TO
MAKE WHITE STUDENTS
UNCOMFORTABLE OR TEXTS THAT ARE
KEY TO UNDERSTANDING, YOU KNOW,
THE RACIAL HISTORY OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, WHICH FRANKLY
IS AN UNCOMFORTABLE HISTORY ARE
BEING BANNED.
AND WE'RE IN DANGER OF
SUGARCOATING, I THINK,
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO DIGEST.
>> ONE OF THE COMMON THEMES OF
THESE LAWS IS THAT THEY SAY WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE THINGS THAT MAKE
KIDS FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT
THEIR RACE.
IS THERE AN ADVANTAGE TO HAVING
KIDS FEEL SLIGHTLY GUILTY ABOUT
THEIR RACE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I PROBABLY
DISAGREE WITH AT LEAST ONE OF MY
COAUTHORS ON THAT.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE A HUGE
MISTAKE IN THIS COUNTRY ABOUT
HOW WE GO ABOUT INDOCTRINATING
CHILDREN AND EACH OTHER INTO
BELIEVING IN THESE ABSTRACT
CATEGORIES OF CLASSIFICATION TO
BEGIN WITH.
SO I THINK THAT WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF EDUCATING CHILDREN TO
THINKING OF THEMSELVES AS WHITE,
THINKING OF THEMSELVES AS BLACK.
AND THEN THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS THAT COME OUT OF THIS
THAT ARE ALL -- YOU KNOW, I
THINK OF A MORE FUNDAMENTAL
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM IS
ACTUALLY FIND WAYS TO TRANSCEND
THE MISTAKE OF RACE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BEEN HURT
BY ITS ASSOCIATION WITH WHAT
SOME CALL WOKENESS?
OR IS THAT A WHOLE BUNCH OF
GIBBERISH?
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE IS GIBBERISH, AND
THERE IS SOMETHING THERE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS HAD A
DIFFICULT TIME STANDING UP TO I
THINK ITS MOST -- ITS LOUDEST
AND ITS MOST VISIBLE NICHE
FRINGE.
SO THE KIND OF VOICES THAT
DOMINATE SOCIAL MEDIA AND VOICES
THAT DOMINATE TWITTER AND
THEREFORE CATCH THE ATTENTION OF
A LOT OF THE MEDIA CLASS ARE NOT
ACTUALLY REPRESENTATIVE OF EVEN
MOST OF THE MINORITY
CONSTITUENTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
AND SO THERE'S A -- THERE'S A
KIND OF MISTAKEN BELIEF THAT
MORE OF THE DEMOCRATIC BASE IS
WOKER THAN IT ACTUALLY IS.
SO I THINK THAT ACTUALLY HAS
HURT POLITICALLY DEMOCRATS, THAT
THEY HAVE VEERED TOO FAR TO A
KIND OF PROGRESSIVE WORLD VIEW
THAT IS NOT SHARED BY NOT EVEN
MOST OF THE COUNTRY BUT NOT MOST
OF THEIR OWN VOTERS.
>> YOU COME FROM A MIXED RACE
BACKGROUND.
HOW DOES THAT HELP INFORM YOUR
THINKING ABOUT NOT CATEGORIZING
PEOPLE BY RACE?
>> WELL, MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
HAS MADE MY BELIEF IN RACIAL
CLASSIFICATION FALL APART.
HAVING CHILDREN WHO I KNOW ARE
DESCENDED FROM AFRICA AND ARE
DESCENDED FROM EUROPE AND THE
WORLD PERCEIVES AS WHITE BUT I
KNOW COULD HAVE BEEN ENSLAVED IN
ANOTHER TIME IN AMERICA, IT
MAKES THESE WALLS OF IDENTITY
FALL DOWN AROUND ME.
I SEE INDIVIDUALS.
I SEE CONFLICTS, HUMAN BEINGS
WITH MIXED UP HISTORIES, AND I
KNOW THAT MANY OTHER PEOPLE
SHARE THIS KIND OF
INTERCONNECTEDNESS THAT WE SEEM
TO DENY WHEN WE FALL BACK ON
WHAT I RECALL THE MYTH OF RACE,
THE VEIL OF RACE THAT FALLS
BETWEEN US WHEN I SEE SOMETHING
AND DENY THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
AND I DON'T MEAN TO DENY RACISM
OR THE HISTORY OF OPPRESSION
THAT EXISTS IN THIS COUNTRY BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO AT SOME
POINT TRANSCEND RACIAL THINKING,
AND THIS IS WHAT KIND OF THE
ANTI-CRT BANS AND THE KINDS OF
BANS THAT FOCUS ON RACIAL
DIFFERENCE BOTH NEGLECT TO DO.
>> ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO YOU WROTE
YOU'RE FROM A MIXED RACE
BACKGROUND BUT YOU HAD I THINK
YOU USED THE PHRASE ETHICAL
OBLIGATION, TO IDENTIFY RACE AS
BLACK.
WHAT MADE YOU CHANGE?
>> THE BIRTH OF MY FIRST CHILD.
I WROTE THAT OP-ED IN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" ARGUING THAT RACE
WASN'T BIOLOGICALLY MEANINGFUL
BUT THAT WAS ESSENTIALLY
ETHNICALLY MEANINGFUL, AND I
REALLY COULDN'T DEFEND THAT WHEN
I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW I MIGHT SEND
MY CHILD OUT INTO THE WORLD AND
TEACH HER WHAT ESSENTIALLY WAS
THE LOGIC OF -- OF THE SLAVE
OWNER, THE LOGIC OF THE
PLANTATION, THAT EVEN THOUGH NO
ONE COULD PERCEIVE THAT A DROP
OF BLACK BLOOD MADE HER BLACK
AND SHE MUST PRESENT HERSELF IN
THE WORLD AS BLACK.
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO SEND OUT
HER OUT IN THE WORLD THEREFORE
I'M WHITE.
I WANTED TO SEND HER OUT IN THE
WORLD SAYING THESE ARE NOT
CATEGORIES MEANINGFUL FOR ME,
THAT I HAVE BOTH OF THESE
HISTORIES IN ME, BUT THESE ARE
NOT BIOLOGICALLY MEANINGFUL.
AND WE HAVE TO FIND A FLEW
LANGUAGE FOR WHAT IS CULTURALLY
AND WHAT IS POLITICALLY AND WHAT
IS SOCIALLY MEANINGFUL.
>> YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT DEFENDER
OF THE CLASSICS, PLATO,
SACRATES, ARISTOTLE.
FIRST OFF TELL ME ABOUT YOUR
FATHER, YOU KNOW, GROWING UP
BLACK IN GALVESTON, TEXAS, BEING
TURNED ONTO THE CLASSICS AND HOW
THAT AFFECTED YOUR THINKING.
>> MY FATHER LIVES -- HE WAS
BORN IN 1937, GREW UP IN
GALVESTON, TEXAS, SEGREGATED
PART OF TOWN.
AND A NEIGHBOR OF HIS, THERE WAS
A PILE OF BOOKS THAT HE FOUND ON
THE NEIGHBOR'S PROPERTY.
AND ONE OF THE BOOKS WAS WILL
DURANT'S, THE STORY OF
PHILOSOPHY.
MY FATHER WAS QUITE YOUNG, UNDER
10 YEARS OLD AND HE SAID HE WAS
FLIPPING THROUGH THE BOOK AND
SAW THIS IMAGE OF SOCRATES AND
HE WAS TRANCE FIXED BY IT.
HOW IT WAS SOMETHING IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO BE PRESERVED IN A BOOK
ACROSS ALL THESE YEARS.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THIS LED HIM
TO READING PLATO'S DIALOGUES AT
SOME POINT.
AND THIS WAS A LIFELINE FOR HIM.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME, I MEAN,
MY FATHER'S IDENTITY WAS TELLING
HIM HE WAS A SECOND CLASS
CITIZEN.
AND THE IDEAS HE ENCOUNTERED IN
THESE TEXTS WERE TELLING HIM
THAT HIS HUMANITY WAS FAR MORE
EXPANSIVE THAN THAT.
AND SO THIS WAS THE FIRST STEP
IN A LIFELONG PROCESS OF
TRANSCENDING THE PAROCHIAL, THE
LOCAL AND GETTING IN TOUCH WITH,
YOU KNOW, THE UNIVERSAL.
AND THIS IS THE MESSAGE THAT MY
FATHER ALWAYS INSTILLED IN ME
AND THAT, YOU KNOW, I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO UPHOLD THIS
KIND OF TIME IN THE CULTURE WARS
WHERE EVERYTHING BECOMES
HYPERPOLARIZED AND EVERYTHING
BECOMES A MATTER OF WHAT
REPRESENTS ME, WHAT IS -- WHAT
IS SPEAKING TO ME DIRECTLY AS
THE CLASSICS AND T